well as you know much has already been
written and said about Stalin and his
stronghold over the Soviet Union but as
with all complex and brutal regimes more
and more is uncovered with time in
Stalin's last crime the plot against the
Jewish Jewish doctors 1948 to 1953
Jonathan Brent along with his co-author
of Vladimir Nawaf has gained access to
never-before-seen KGB documents and
presidential and party archives to
unravel the truth behind several aspects
of the Stalin regime including the
conspiracy against the doc the Jewish
doctors and a cover-up regarding his
death Stalin's last crime is a
fascinating and enlightening read that
will go a long way to further explaining
the drama and impact that this point of
history has had on the 20th century
Jonathan Brent holds a PhD from the
University of Chicago and is editorial
director of Yale University Press and
founder of the distinguished annals of
communism series and is my great
pleasure to introduce to you Jonathan
Brent
thank you very much it's it's really a
pleasure to be here in my hometown and
I'm grateful to the library for inviting
me to speak about this book when I
started working on this book I thought
it was going to be a matter of
assembling documents and getting to the
truth of what happened to the Jewish
doctors in 1953 and when I began to be
interested in it
vladimir pavlovich no muff said to me
you've heard of the doctors plant I said
yes of course I said is there anything
new about it he said well yes there
there interesting new documents I said
well I can't quite understand what the
interest of this would be because the
doctors were innocent when thing he said
no I said you mean the doctors were
guilty he said no he said it's much more
complicated than that and as I began to
look at these documents that have a kind
of extraordinary quality of coming up
out of the depths of hell frankly I
began to realize the truth of what
Vladimir no muff had said to me after
Lady Macbeth murders Duncan she's
walking about trying to wash the blood
off her hands and she says hell is murky
and the hell of Stalin's world is murky
it is a world of blood it is a world of
conspiracy it is a world in which there
is no basic trust between individuals we
can hardly conceptualize it being born
and bred in the United States these
documents gave me an insight into that
world not just into the historical
reality of the doctor's plot it isn't
the simple question of arguing the truth
or the the the falsity of the charges
that were brought against the doctors
rather this this complex of materials
that over a 10-year period
Wladimir no muff was able to tease out
of the KGB in the presidential archives
gives us an insight and I somewhat
immodestly must say it is the first real
historically documented insight that we
have as to the inner workings of that
Stalinist hell and so what I would like
to talk about now is not so much the
doctors plot and all of the mechanisms
of it but rather what this hell was the
conspiratorial world of Stalin's Russia
in brief though for those of you who may
not know the doctors plot was 450 years
thought to have been a false accusation
made by the Russia the Soviet government
in 1953 in January 1953 to the effect
that Jewish doctors were murdering
Kremlin leaders this was put on the
front page of Pravda On January 13 1953
it created a sensation around the world
such that even Eleanor Roosevelt sent a
letter to President Eisenhower
beseeching him to intervene on behalf of
the Jews of Russia because people
smelled a new holocaust people could
feel it in the air at the time and men
of course many of the Jews of the Soviet
Union were convinced that that is what
was now going to happen why because in
1948 after the create
of the State of Israel and the rebuff
that Stalin had gotten from David
ben-gurion who said to him in effect we
do not want Soviet advisors helping the
Israeli army in the war against the
Arabs because we do not want to have
happen in Israel what I know
ben-gurion said I know happened in Spain
and with that the Soviet advisors were
sent back to Czechoslovakia and wherever
else they came from and Stalin became
convinced that Israel was in the
American camp and he conceived an
implacable hatred for the State of
Israel from that point on even though
there was great euphoria in in the
Soviet Union among the Jewish population
when Golda Meir came to Moscow in
September 1948 and the streets were
flooded with with Jews thronging about
her and and Molotov wife of vyacheslav
molotov the foreign minister of the
soviet union who signed who who created
with Ribbentrop the ripped the the
hitler stalin pact and who's famous
because of his cocktail that was thrown
at the at the czars army at the time of
the revolution Molotov wife was a woman
whose name was Pearl car puffs kiya
pearl Karpov scale was Jewish she
changed her name to Polina Jamuna which
means Pearl in Russian and when Golda my
ear came to Moscow in September of 1948
it was pearl Karpov skya
who led her about and brought her to the
coral synagogue and said to her in
Yiddish you've been I need assure talked
her that unfortunately got back to
Stalin
and in that means I'm a daughter of the
Jewish people and in the Kuril synagogue
the balconies were filled overwhelmingly
with people begging to Seigle to my ear
they thought that the balconies would
break maybe ten thousand people jammed
into this structure and on the walls
there were the signs on Israel high
which of course is a traditional deeply
resonant phrase over the centuries that
means the Jewish people lives in
probably incomprehensible through all of
the disasters that have be said it the
Jewish people still lives Stalin took it
to be a statement of Jewish nationalism
and he saw in the outpouring of good
feeling and the love that and and the
excitement of the time he saw something
dangerous to his regime why because it
represented a bond among Jewish people
that was deeper than anything that he
could have imagined it was
incomprehensible what are they so
excited about Israel is over there this
is the Soviet Union this is the land of
good and plenty this is this is where
everybody has the dream of living in
joyful happy fraternal relations with
everyone else with equality and justice
and so and so and yet they seemed these
Jews they seemed to club together in an
unhealthy way and Stalin recognized
there was a problem the first problem
was with his fellow Molotov who was
married to this young shushanna and a
year later jumped Regina in 1949 was
arrested despite the fact that she was
an ardent ardent Stalinist and remained
an ardent Stalinist to the day she died
defending him against any criticism
she was exiled to Kazakhstan in a gulag
and there she remained until Stalin's
death but it wasn't pearl Karpov skaia
that Stalin was really going after it
was Molotov himself the reason he was
going after Molotov through his
initially through his wife but later by
the time the doctor's plot comes to
fruition in 1953 directly against
Molotov himself is that Molotov made an
unwise choice on various occasions the
unwise choice he made beginning soon
after the war was over was to let it be
known that he and other leaders of the
Soviet Union were quite pleased at the
new relationship with the West with
America with Great Britain they printed
a glowing comment of of Churchill's in
saying that Stalin was a great hero a
father of the people and blah blah blah
blah blah blah blah and they printed
this in Pravda and Stalin who was in the
Crimea and Saatchi recuperating because
he suffered at some sort of a nervous
collapse we still collapse we still do
not know exactly what it was but Stalin
wasn't such recuperating his health and
here is Molotov in Moscow along with
mine cough and very and who chef's
parading around pretending that they're
in charge of the country and furthermore
saying foolishly that they are hoping
that there will be a relaxation in the
censorship saying that they are hoping
that now will be a time when bridges can
be built and so on and so forth and
Stalin sent them furious telegrams from
the Crimea as soon as he saw this and he
said what are you calves
playing in a barnyard kicking up your
heels you stupid fools he said cannot
you see the enemy
don't you know that Churchill is just
saying these things for his own good to
cleanse his dirty conscience at what he
has done behind our backs with the
French don't you know that they are
trying to destroy us you you idiots
this was in 1946 in 1952 in December of
1952 when the decision was made to print
the article in January about the doctors
plot Stalin assembled his Politburo and
he said to them here look at you blind
men kittens he called them he said this
nation will perish because you do not
recognize the enemy and so from 1946 to
1952 this thought was just stating in
the mind of Joseph Stalin and indeed he
was probably right they didn't know who
the enemy was because ultimately the
enemy was Stalin himself
to come back now to the conspiratorial
aspect of all this it has been thought
of course for 50 years that the Jewish
doctors were quite innocent it didn't
start out that way
the way it started out was that the
Jewish doctors were guilty but lo and
behold almost instantaneously after
Stalin died on March 5th 1953 50 years
ago this past March within three weeks
by March 27th there was already within
the inner circle of the Kremlin
leadership a document that was written
by Baria calling for the termination of
the plot against the doctors in fact
within a week after Stalin's death
burial ow assumed the highest post in
the country in terms of the security
services called for the dismantling of
the doctors plot why was it so urgent
why was this doctor's plot so urgently
called for by the rut the Soviet leaders
at the time unmarked on April the 4th
there is a big article in Pravda
Jewish doctors have been maligned by the
security services by the adventurist
provocateurs working in the MGB that was
the forerunner of the KGB and it named
names it said that MD rumen and
Ignatieff who was the the the head of
the MGB at the time these people were
just out for themselves they were trying
to make trouble and they had blamed the
Jewish doctors for everything and it was
a a total fraud and it had been trumped
up and fabricated from stem to stern and
at that point the case was closed the
doctors were let out of prison and
instead of it being a plot by the Jewish
doctors against the government it was
turned on its
head and for fifty years has been
thought to have been a plot by the
government against the Jewish doctors
but no one thought that it was something
else and this is what these documents
prove and this is why understanding that
the conspiratorial nature of that world
is so important it wasn't just a plot
against the Jewish doctors it was a plot
on the part of Stalin against his own
government and this is why it was the
most powerful weapon that he had at the
end of his life in the last three to
five years of his life for turning his
country back to where it was in the
1930s so that he could reassert total
control over the country gain complete
mastery over these blind men kittens who
he felt were slowly slowly taking the
power away from him partly because of
his own physical debility at the time
and so getting into the inner workings
of that conspiracy I'll give you one
example of how this conspiracy worked in
1948 Stalin's most powerful and
important Politburo comrade andrey
zhdanov became ill and he went to val
died a health resort for the so-called
nomenclature the the elite of the of the
soviet government where they would go he
became ill and on August 31st he died
now on August 29th a doctor named Lydia
F team Ashok who was the Linda trip of
her day wrote a letter to Stalin in
which she said these doctors who are
caring for comrades done off they have
estimated the unquestionably grave
nature of his illness and she said to
him if measures are not taken to change
the regimen of treatment I predict a
fateful outcome and she signed it and
she put it in a sealed envelope and they
put a wax seal on it and they shot it to
Moscow through covert channels and
nothing happened there was no phone call
the next day from Kuznetsov in the in
the Politburo or from Vlasic who was the
head of the Kremlin guards or from
abbakumov who was minister of state
security or puss-puss Gorbachev who was
Stalin's secretary from nobody nothing
nothing happened silence
two days later standoff dies and it
seems as though team Ashok's prophecy
had come true what happened in those
three days from August 28th to August
31st well in December 1952 when Stalin
gathers his Politburo and he he says
look there has been a plot against me
and the Soviet government going on at
the highest levels why look at this
letter that Lydia Tim Ashok sent to me
in or or not it wasn't actually
addressed to him it was addressed to the
head of the Kremlin guard sent to Vlasic
general Vlasic the head of the Kremlin
guards it is dated August 29 1948 two
days later Jean roof is dead this letter
was never shown to me don't you
understand comrades this Vlasic has been
guilty of suppressing this vitally
important piece of information this a
buck off who Vlasic should have sent it
to suppress it as well these people are
traitors they're undermining the country
there is a plot
against us well it's taken us 50 years
but we have discovered the following
that letter was sent to General Vlasic
on the 29th of August on the 30th of
August it was passed on to Victor
abbakumov the head of the ministry of
security how do we know this because we
have a document that reads as follows
dear Comrade Stalin attached is a letter
from Lydia Timur shook in which she
makes the claim that the doctors who are
caring for andrey zhdanov are not paying
proper attention to him attached is a
copy of the electrocardiogram she took
of Jean offs heart I request that you
pay that that you look at this and at
the bottom of a Baku muffs memorandum to
Stalin is Stalin's signature which it
was always a big C and a TC in Cyrillic
is s T and underneath that in his hand
reads into the archive which is means
take it and throw it in the garbage can
there was no archive just take it and
throw at me it was typical Lenin did
exactly the same thing but when he
accuses abbakumov
and Vlasic in 1948 there's no mention of
the fact that this was ever passed on to
Stalin furthermore neither of Okuma
Fleur Vlasic ever mentioned after months
of torture that they had ever passed it
on to Stalin himself what happened how
is this possible
why would Stalin do nothing can you
imagine I mean you might say well he's
70
years old he's suffering from hardening
of the arteries his memory is going and
so on and so forth maybe he doesn't
remember exactly what happened on on
August the 30th 1948 after all it was
five years later practically but can you
imagine if if if Don if Dick Cheney were
in Bethesda Naval Hospital and a member
of the FBI the head of the FBI let us
say puts a memo in President Bush's hand
and says you know dr. so-and-so and dr.
so-and-so in Bethesda Naval Hospital are
murdering your vice president do you
think that that George Bush would just
write into the archive and now be the
end of it
no it wouldn't happen that way andrey
zhdanov was the second most powerful man
in the soviet union at the time it was
he in 1947 who gave the all-important
speech in Poland to all of the satellite
countries outlining what Soviet foreign
policy with respect to the United States
in the West was going to be it wasn't
Molotov it was done off who did that it
was done off who gave the who made the
all-important report on on on on
amitabha and azure Shenko and other
writers in 1947 that started what was
called the Don of China the the
censorship against the writers that was
such a blight on Soviet culture for so
long it was Don off who rebuked trust
the coverage and and and silenced him
with the simple words you don't write
music that the average Soviet worker can
hum and and
it was done off who would go to Stalin's
dacha and play the piano for him he
actually knew how to do something most
of the Politburo leaders of course came
up from the peasantry they were
basically illiterate like Khrushchev and
others they couldn't play the piano they
couldn't do anything he jonov could talk
about literature he was a friend of
gorky's he gave the keynote speech in
1934 to the International Congress of
writers held in Moscow he was a literate
man and furthermore in 1949 after his
death a year after his death his son
Yuri's Don off married Stalin's daughter
and as fat Lana
alleluiah Eva writes in her memoir there
was no real love between them and it is
quite probable that it was a marriage
that was made for the purpose of a
political alignment not because fat lana
loved yuri so what happened with Zidane
off how did this work and how did it
become a Jewish plot after all Donna was
being cared for by a man named yogorov
who was Russian he was the head of the
Kremlin hospital system a doctor named
Vinogradov who had gone with Stalin to
Tehran at the conference he was
something like Stalin's personal
physician he was Russian a man named
vasilenko who was Ukrainian not Jewish
and a doctor named maior off' who was
russian how did this become a Jewish
plot of there was one doctor who was
Jewish a technician named Sofia carpi
who was dismissed from Val died in on
August the 7th and had no further
contact with dronov
so of all the doctors who were treating
Donna off only one and that the EKG
technician was Jewish so how did this
become a Jewish plot that's another part
of the conspiratorial aspect and that's
one reason it took five years it took
Stalin five years to make it into a
Jewish plot now the doctors as now have
said to me they weren't guilty but they
also weren't innocent house is possible
again in Macbeth when Macbeth is on the
heath and he's just won the battle he
says to himself in the twilight of the
end of the battle he says nothing is but
what is not and that is the Twilight
world of this hell the doctors who are
the cream of Soviet medicine at the time
including Stalin's personal physician
Vinogradov are involved I here is Don
off he comes in July to vol die to be
taken care of and when he comes they
diagnose him they have an EKG technician
Sophie carpi she takes EKGs of his heart
she discovers that he has something
called a left bundle branch block it's
not exactly a heart attack but it's like
it I don't know all of the medical
terminology but it's it's a dangerous
condition and so he was put on a strict
regime of bed rest that lasted two weeks
in the in the habit of the day the
manner of the day the fashion of the
times he should have been in bed for at
least a month he was given two weeks he
started feeling better what happened
well this you're eased on off who
eventually married Svetlana
allelujah v''e the year after his
father's death had become elevated he
was a
one of Stalin's favorites and he became
elevated into the Central Committee and
in the Central Committee he became the
head of the science sector of the
Central Committee which means to say
which is to say that he was in charge of
all scientific things going on in the
central it in in the Soviet Union and it
was his job to ensure ideological purity
and to supervise what was going on bla
bla bla anyway for years and years
people had been getting complaints about
this quack botanist known as lysenko TD
Lysenko much has been written about this
man but this one little story has never
been written about when his father when
enraged on earth would get such letters
he would put them into the archive and
forget about it because he didn't want
to be bothered with the problems of
listen go
but the young star off seeing these
letters letters from distinguished
scientists who would say things like
this Lysenko has not discovered one
single new species of plant his his work
is a fraud he cannot any longer be in
charge of Soviet agriculture which
Lysenko was Stalin adored him he was he
was to Stalin what Russ Putin was to
nicholas ii he was a man who promised a
miracle he he would tell him why I will
I will make weep for you that doesn't
have just two ears
it'll have seven years I'll make
tomatoes out of potatoes and potatoes
out of tomatoes and he had this theory
of neo Lamarckian theory that that
acquired characteristics could be
inherited and he saw no reason why it
should only be the sex cells through
which inheritance could be transmitted
that seemed rather elitist bourgeois
after all it it what about the rest of
the cells are they just peasants
and and he developed a theory that every
cell of the body was capable of
reproduction sexual reproduction or that
is to say reproduction in which genetic
duplication would take place and you
could give birth to new species in this
fashion it was rather avant-garde at the
time given what we know about cloning
now and so on but it wasn't intended
that way
in any case Eurasia on earth comes from
along and he gets these letters and he
looks at them and he says well you know
I think maybe we should have a little
session and talk about all of this so he
asks his boss in the Central Committee a
man by the name of sue Slav can I have a
little meeting about the sink coasters
Oh and so we it happens there's 16 17
lecturers and science from around the
Soviet Union they come they talk about
Lysenko theories there is no steno gram
of this meeting it would be interesting
if one could eventually be produced but
what is known is that at this meeting my
old criticism was made of lysenko and
lysenko theories and so on and so forth
and because of the nature of the Soviet
world
it was immediately reported to both
Lysenko and Stalin that this happened
because everybody was informing on
everybody else you have to remember that
in 1950 there were 10 million informants
in the Soviet Union this is the estimate
made by by the head of the ministry of
security
ten million informants like you and me
and it grew and grew and I would inform
on you before you would inform on me and
this is the way the system worked no
many were unpaid some were paid and some
were unpaid but this Lydia Timur shook
was one of them
so the next thing is Stalin is furious
that anybody should dare call Lysenko
into question and he convenes the
Politburo uris Don off the father sue
Slav Chapelle off' who was working there
from whom we have an account of this
meeting and various others and he says
who authorized this meeting dead silence
everybody is scared to death who
authorized this meeting nobody raises a
hand
finally Dmitrich appeal of stands up and
he says i authorized this meeting
Comrade Stalin really you authorized
this meeting how dare you authorize this
meeting who gave you that permission for
a meeting like this without the
permission of the Central Committee how
dare you do something like this and
Shapiro said but but I beseech you do
with me whatever you want Comrade Stalin
but you have to understand that lysenko
lysenko theories need to be investigated
and I beg of you hold an investigation
of these theories and so on and so forth
it went on and as he recounts in his
memoir Stalin turned white he takes out
his pipe he fills his pipe and as I read
this account I kept thinking of that
scene in the in the Untouchables where
where where
Capone takes that baseball bat and
starts walking around the table
and that's what this scene was and
finally he fills his pipe and he starts
smoking in this smoke fills the room and
he says whoever whoever is guilty of
this will be punished in an exemplary
fashion and then he looked at Don off
and he said in cases like this we must
look to the Father and not the Sun why
because he assumed that
yuris Don off could only have done this
if his father had given him permission
to do this or alternatively this was a
pretext to begin an action against this
happened in April of 1948 by July 1948
it had evolved in the following fashion
Stalin called another meeting and he
advised Don off that he looked a little
pasty looked a little puffy as indeed he
did because he had been a hard drinker
all of his life he was suffering from
hypertension he was only 50 years old
but nevertheless 50 in the Soviet Union
at that time was already like 75 here
and particularly because he had gone
through the hard times of the war and so
on and so forth and it was a little
short of breath Lee he said why don't
you go to Valle die and take a health
rest this was in early July exactly at
that same time your age Don off the son
writes a letter to Stalin in which he
tells Stalin that he made a terrible
blunder in this in organizing this
lecture on lysenko he said the first
mistake I had was to have a point of
view of my own
how dare I do that I should certainly
have have checked with the Central
Committee and he said the second blunder
I made was was that I didn't come out
forcefully enough in favor of Lysenko
and this is a wonderful thing he says in
fact the very small inadequacies in
Lysenko that I was pointing to were in
the nature of my admiration for Lysenko
because I would like him to correct
these things so that he can be even more
triumphant and he ends his letter which
is a long letter two three pages long by
saying I will correct my mistakes with
my action and he sends it to Stalin on
the seventh or the 10th of July 1948 at
exactly the same time that his father
goes to Valle die even though the
incident took place in April so it's
clear that they're related Stalin does
nothing with this letter very much but
in the end of July Chapelle off who had
been part of that Central Committee
meeting has organized now a big
conference in Moscow on the biological
sciences and agriculture and so on
chaired by Lysenko and at this meeting
Lysenko gives a overwhelming argument in
favor of of his Lamarckian theories he
destroys the best minds of Soviet
biology they are all beaten to a pulp
with his oblong red potatoes and his
yellow tomatoes and his his cells that
are dividing and subdividing all by
themselves and at the end of the
conference which takes place on August
the 7th 1948 he reads Yuri down offs
letter
and on August the 7th that same day as
the conference end URIs Don offs letter
to Stalin is printed in Pravda on page 5
now
who would know what that letter was all
about what what he URIs Donna is
apologizing for something nobody knew
even took place outside of a very small
circle of people but the circle of
people who knew that it took place were
the scientists and so therefore all the
scientists who took who participated in
the the lysenko conference understood
quite well that they had been destroyed
now they were totally that there was no
exit for them behind lysenko stood the
Central Committee behind the Central
Committee stood Stalin and there was no
exit and even Yuri's Don off who had
broached even the slightest hint of
criticism had been silenced but word of
this leaked out somehow to the doctors
involved I and on August the 7th the
same day that the Lysenko conference is
over and the same day that the the
Yuri's dawn off letter is published in
Pravda a very significant thing happens
the only Jewish doctor serving to care
for Don off at that time
Sophia carpi is dismissed and from
August the 7th until August 28th when
team Ashok comes on the scene nobody is
taking an EKG of andrey zhdanov now how
did this happen why did it happen it's
utterly unexplained we do not know
but we do know that at exactly the same
time that the EKG technician is
dismissed and no new one is put in place
we also know that my or off' his on duty
attending doctor goes fishing and cannot
be found when andrey zhdanov has an
attack of emphysema and his lips turned
blue and he almost becomes unconscious
because he can't breathe we do know that
the attending nurse cannot be found when
andrey zhdanov late at night rings the
bell again and again and again and again
because she had left the window open and
even in july in the north of russia it
becomes cold and poor andrey zhdanov was
cold and he was not supposed to get out
of bed but the nurse can't be found so
he gets out of bed to close the window
we do know that exactly at this time
he's encouraged to go for fairly long
walks and we know that he was encouraged
to go to the movies and in their notes
because we have the doctor's notes from
that time and we've used them in this
book we even know that the doctors were
intending to send him on an automobile
trip to moscow which was o 90 minutes or
so from valdi or more than that 90 miles
or so from vol die a couple hours drive
which would have been stressful and we
know furthermore that ruggiano's
condition continued to deteriorate and
yet the doctors do nothing they do
nothing so what has happened here
it's that murky world of Lady Macbeth
Stalin insisted on something he insisted
that all the people of the Soviet Union
be vigilant to be vigilant what did that
mean it meant to be always on alert to
be always on guard to make sure that
your neighbor isn't doing something
wrong to make sure that what's going on
in the by the foreman in your plant is
okay to make sure that this guy over
there who's pretending to be a Russian
isn't really a Jew it means to make sure
that everything is good ultimately it
means to be constantly informing on your
neighbor and it means to interpret the
will of the government properly you
don't need a direct order if you're
vigilant you catch the signals and what
were the signals that were gathering
together involved I at the time well
they knew the doctors knew enough to
know that Donna had fallen out of favor
with Stalin they knew this because
information about that stormy meeting in
the Politburo had begun to leak out to
them in selected ways they knew quite
concretely because Eurasian aufs letter
was printed in Pravda on the same day as
the end of the lysenko conference and
therefore what did they know they knew
that this man who had been the favorite
son and as Molotov said after Kirov
Stalin loved Don off best after Kirov
who had also been assassinated in 1934
he loved his Don off best and is quite
true and everybody knew this and so this
man was now out of favor and what do you
do to people who are out of favor do you
treat them with all the diligence and
due care at your disposal No you ignore
them
as much as possible and so on August the
29th
yogorov who's the head of the kremlin
hospital who has a very sick patient on
his hands decides he has to go to Moscow
for a dinner party and on the 30th after
Lydia team Ashok has written her letter
to the authorities yet Gaurav and and a
Vinogradov and vasenka and my or if they
all get together and they say what are
we going to do what are we going to do
about this and they get John offs wife
involved who is a bit of a harridan and
is very bossy and even Stalin couldn't
tolerate her and and she calls a meeting
and she accuses everybody and she sort
of blows everything up out of proportion
and and and and and then the the idea is
that by doing this they've aired it and
they've ventilated it and there's no
longer any threat what do they do well
on the 31st the the morning of the day
that John off dies Vinogradov and you
gotta fly back again to Moscow leaving
only my or off' and Vasily Anka in
charge of the second most powerful man
in the Soviet Union and my or off' went
fishing and so the medical staff of all
died was stripped to the bones Timur
shook had gone back to Moscow there was
no EKG technician everybody's left the
scene and Vina Granof goes back to
Moscow and he holds a meeting with other
chief diagnosed Soviet diagnosticians
and he says to them listen isn't the
treatment that we're giving it isn't
isn't the diagnosis that we have made of
Donna's house correct they say correct
and it's there boldly in the stenograph
the diagnosis is correct everything is
correct it's correct correct correct
correct and at four o'clock that date on
us dead everything is correct it's like
a Polish friend of mine said about her
son's wedding when I congratulated her
and said I thought everything
perfect she said yes everything is
perfect and everything is a disaster and
everything was correct and everything
was incorrect and it and and and it is
that Twilight world of Macbeth because
Vienna Granoff did not go to Moscow in
order really to understand the nature of
the illness or to find means of treating
it more effectively he went because he
was afraid of timox letter Timur shook
then then then then is vindicated and
what happens you would think after Timur
shook is vindicated that at least then
the authorities would take action but no
no action is taken instead a week later
she's called into yogorov's office and
read the riot act and a session takes
place in which they in which all of the
doctors who were involved I vasilenko my
or of Vinogradov and the the man who
conducted the autopsy and you Gaurav
they say to her you you are so ignorant
of medicine you don't deserve to
practice medicine in the Kremlin
Hospital any longer and they fire her oh
now she's furious and she writes letter
after letter to Politburo members and so
on and so forth bemoaning her fate and
saying look after all I was right about
underaged on earth nothing happens
silence there's not a peep not from
Vlasak not from abbakumov not from
Stalin certainly and what happens to the
doctors nothing in they go on with their
lives and what happens to Timur shook
she's fired and she sent to an outlying
clinic far from the Kremlin Hospital and
this is 1948 so how did this turn into
the doctors plot did did Stalin intend
at that time for this to be the core of
the doctors plot
the answer to the question it seems to
me is yes and no Stalin certainly knew
of the Timur shook letter he knew what
was implied in it and he did nothing to
save the life of his most valued
lieutenant instead he allowed the
doctors to continue their negligent
treatment to which some of them
confessed ultimately but five years
later it's all turned around and all of
a sudden the doctors are thrown out of
their jobs and team Ashok is awarded the
Order of Lenin on the very same day that
the article in Pravda appears and then
three months later it's taken away from
her when the doctors plot is dismantled
and unfortunately I have no more time to
talk about all of the various inter
tangle Minh this plot but it is tangled
it is dark it is a world that is like an
all alternate world it's a world in
which everything takes place at the
highest levels of government in in in in
in conspiracy and that the conspiracy
and again like a Shakespeare play the
conspiracies at the top of Stalin and
and of Vlasic and abbakumov are then
mirrored down below in the subplots of
tema shook and yogorov and the other
doctors involved I it is conspiracy
within conspiracy within conspiracy
within conspiracy ultimately and I'll
end with this and and then take
questions but ultimately and and sadly
and and horribly this plot against the
Jewish doctors was not even
ultimately aimed at the Jews the Jews
were pretext what it was aimed that
ultimately was America it was aimed at
at the the entity that Stalin had
identified as the real enemy
the real enemy was the West the real
enemy was America and he was going to
get at America through the doctors no
differently than Israel is being used
today by many of the Arab countries and
Islamic extremists it was a pretext a
diversion in order to turn the country
against America and unfortunately I
don't have enough time to talk about all
of the ins and outs of this but in a
kind of a nutshell Stalin was convinced
that there was going to be a war with
the United States of America it was
going to be a nuclear war he had
exploded the atom bomb in 1949 they were
furiously at work on the hydrogen bomb
the recently published memoirs of Sarah
go beriah that the son of Lavrentiy
Beria who was one of the leading
physicists of the time working on the
atom bomb project testifies amply to the
fact that everyone involved in the
project understood that they were
preparing the armaments for an exchange
with the United States of America was
this going to happen in 1953 no would it
have happened in 1955 no but Stalin knew
it was going to happen this I believe
and it's too complicated to get into all
of how we know this to be so but this is
what terrified people like Khrushchev
and Baria so much and they understood
that this was connected to the doctors
plot because it was through the doctors
plot that Stalin was going to make
public the accusation that the America
were planning a nuclear first strike
against the Soviet Union
it seems bizarre and I'll only mentioned
briefly what this is in the book it's
called the intelligence phantasmagoria
because it is a total phantasmagoria but
we discovered a plot called the plan of
the internal blow that was going to be a
revelation to the world that America was
going to fire two nuclear missiles from
the windows of the American Embassy in
Moscow that overlooked the Kremlin it's
absolute science fiction but but they
had imagined the concept of tactical
nuclear weapons at this point they were
going to explode over the Kremlin it was
going to melt everything and this was
going to be the first strike in
America's war against the Soviet Union
and the invasion was not going to take
place across the European frontier the
invasion was going to take place across
the sino-soviet frontier and the
information and the documentation for
this is contained in the book it's quite
an extraordinary thing the American the
CIA the American intelligence didn't
know anything about this in fact nobody
knew anything about it and as soon as
Stalin was dead they deep-sixed this as
fast as they could they shot this man
vartholomio who'd been giving them this
this song and dance and no word has ever
crept out of the crypt about the plan of
the internal blow until now but Stalin
was going to link that with the doctors
plot with the sedition and the
traitorous nosov abbakumov and Vlasic
ins and Molotov and Mikoyan and all of
this was going to come to the surface in
the spring of 1953 and it would have
created a world crisis and it was in the
conditions of world crisis that Stalin
could regain his mastery and because
yeah and again of his country he would
be the master of his house he would be
the boss why he would be able to get rid
of all of these Molotov Sande McCoy
yawns he would put everybody in his
place
because the conspiratorial system can
can succeed only in times of crisis
it is crisis that makes power legitimate
in a conspiratorial regime stability
leads to stagnation which is exactly
what happened when Soviet leaders after
Stalin backed away from the crisis
mentality and what did it lead to it led
to stagnation because that system is
Unruh formal it is ultimately Unruh for
mobile because it does not exist
according to laws it exists according to
conspiracies and I think for me one of
the great lessons of reading all of this
material understanding it is the
understanding that there is a there
there are two different kinds of
political systems in the world
one is a system ruled by law and and and
legitimacy is granted by law and the
other is the conspiratorial system the
system of power of force this is the
system of Stalin who was Hitler's
teacher and not the other way around
it's not well known that it was the NKVD
the KGB that trained the Gestapo up
until 1936 it was Stalin and the cotton
Massacre that represented the first real
mass murder of the Second World War that
the Germans uncovered and understood how
it was possible to cover these things up
and it is all the little Stalin's in the
world the Saddam Hussain's the Fidel
Castro's and these are not small matters
just because they're small countries
they represent a form of power that is
ultimately inimical to liberal democracy
to the rule of law it isn't simply
another system it is a an assault on the
concept of law and the legitimacy of
power which is perhaps the most precious
thing that we have in the West and I'll
stop there
yes sir
Ilya Ehrenberg that in 1948 Stalin
wanted to deport Jews to Siberia and
Ilya Ehrenberg who was his favorite
talked him out of it he said it would
make a pusses this is any basis for
their there's a basis for it it's
complicated
we've discovered the letter that Ilya
Ehrenberg sent to Stalin I read you the
last part of the letter because it's
really quite revealing let's see if I
could find it he says yes this is the
letter that Aaron Aaron Berg wrote you
understand dear Joseph Vissarionovich
that I myself cannot decide these
questions and therefore I dare to write
to you capitalized you there is talk of
an important political act and I decided
to request that you charge a leading
government figure to inform me whether
the publication of this document that is
to say a letter asking for the
deportation of Jews by Jews it was going
to be like the sort of document that the
leaders of the Warsaw Ghetto or the Lodz
ghetto would have to sign you see
whether the publication of this document
is desirable and whether it is desirable
to have my signature on it I perfectly
understand that if it could be useful
for the defense of our motherland and
the movement for world peace I will
immediately sign the letter to the
editorial board with deep respect Ilya
Ehrenburg now the question of whether
there was going whether there were going
to be deportations is been one that has
been raised again and again and again
about the doctors plot we have found I
should say vladimir oma found in the
archive two most extraordinary documents
that have never come to light before
that we have published in this book they
are orders to construct four new large
concentration camps in Kazakhstan and in
the Far East and what was the purpose of
these camps after all they still had
Magadan they still had the whole of the
Soviet gulag wasn't that big enough for
the Jews or for whoever they were going
to put in there for Molotov wasn't it
big enough for Molotov and Miquelon no
they were planning a deportation I'm
convinced of it the fact some people
argue against it on the grounds that no
order for deportation was found but in
1944 the Chechens were deported and the
order for the deportation was signed
five days after the deportation took
place so the fact that there is no order
proves nothing because again this is a
society that is conspiratorial in nature
and it is not a society ruled by law and
all of the documents that are in these
archives are not a testament to the
legalistic nature of that society but
rather to the fact that every piece of
paper was political and could be used as
a weapon anyway yes yeah all this
activity and in 48 relate to the
activity in the Far East by the Russians
as the mainland Chinese were
deteriorating and that eventually within
a year so led up to the Korean conflict
and and and the role of Russia trying to
keep control over the Koreans in that
whole set of the world and did that
divert some of this other activity into
that into that focus do you mean was
Stalin was his attention divided or do
you know that that how did he react to
that the transition in China to the cow
he totally miscalculated what was going
on in the Far East he didn't really
understand it well he in fact Stalin was
least
adapt when he was dealing with things
beyond the borders of the Soviet Union
he was most adept when he was dealing
with his own people that he was an
expert on that was his chess game but he
didn't really grasp the enormity of what
was going on in the Far East at the time
and the vast shift in power that was
taking place over there and I think he
was taken by surprise ultimately but
that was something that he didn't really
come to understand until later I think
in 48 he still was very confident you
know he was very methodical he never he
never worked precipitously about
anything we have some material in the
book that shows how absolutely
methodical even in grave situations he
was always wanting more information
always wanting you to dig your your
grave a little bit deeper and and bring
as many of your friends along sited and
on which you focused were there many
other instances over a period of many
years
which implicated Jewish doctors and if
so was it the same methodology which was
used a sick person and doctors
disappearing well see this this is the
great mystery which is how does
something that takes place where there
are no Jewish doctors how does that get
turned into a Jewish plot and and this
is where the ingenuity of the KGB or the
MGB as it was called came into play
because they finally got a Jewish doctor
in in in 1950 this men Ettinger yes
where the accusations made of whether
they they really were Jewish actors or
not were there many accusations over a
period of many years or any different
case back back in the thirties that one
case then
back in the 30s there had been an
accusation that a dr. Levin or Levin had
been implicated in the deaths of various
important Soviet figures like Maxim
Gorky and mention ski and and so on and
query chef and the accusation was made
that this Jewish doctor working with
several Russian doctors was involved in
poisoning them and in fact when the
doctors plot of 1953 was going to was
coming in to its ultimate form achieving
its ultimate form this material from the
1930s was brought back into the
accusations and and Stalin said you see
it's the same old thing you see there's
a precedent for this but between them
between the 30s and the 50s they really
had no there had not been accusations
all along there had not been against
Jewish doctors this one major this was
this one case was blown up the whole no
no it expanded it like mushrooms it was
by 1953 it wasn't just Donna who had
been murdered it was a scherbakov it was
Georgi Dimitrov it was men by the name
of Andreev who actually wasn't murdered
but they claimed that these doctors
quote-unquote led him astray by giving
him a cocaine solution to which he
became addicted and I was asked then
then is it is that your belief that the
main aspect of this whole thing is the
implication of the Jewish doctors and
these people disappearing were just
simply sight a side situation and they
were expendable yes or if it weren't for
the Jewish doctors being involved would
they have disappeared anyway well Georgi
Dimitrov was somebody stalin wanted to
get out of the way and
I have no doubt but that some of these
doctors worked on Dimitrov they did they
worked in fact the same doctors who
worked on Dimitrov worked understand off
they the thing is that none of them were
Jewish and so is that so you see it was
this one case the case of scherbakov
where there was a Jewish doctor named
Anton Guerra and they they rounded him
up but they didn't initially arrest him
because he was a doctor they arrested
him because they knew he held ardent
views about the State of Israel and he
was he was very very angry and upset
with the Soviet government for the
anti-jewish policies that were being put
into effect the the so-called anti
cosmopolitan campaign of the of 48 49 50
that was reaching a Zenith in in 1949
1950 and and this man anything Garin was
one of the great diagonals like
arresting dr. Spock
almost everybody knew editing care he
was you were sick you called dr.
Ettinger if you know if Bush is sick he
gets dr. Anton Guerra to come you know
so they arrested him anyway I see other
hands yes sir
one aspect of this of this web of
conspiracy that I know you deal with in
your book but we didn't get to was as
this disaster of the deportation the
Jews and so forth and possible war in
crisis the the Politburo Khrushchev
variants of worth took their own took
matters into their own hands and killed
Stalin you believe am i you're saying is
why I mean what is the is there a
smoking gun it's mine
there's no no ultimate smoking gun what
we have though is the medical report
that the doctors made during the last
days of Stalin's life and this medical
report shows a that all of the accounts
of Stalin's death that we have up to now
are fallacious whether purposefully
invented or not they are fabrications of
one sort or another
number one number two there are symptoms
that Stalin exhibited that were never
made public for instance that he was
vomiting blood now people who suffer
from a stroke generally go to sleep
quietly and never wake up they don't
turn blue with cyanosis and vomit blood
that in itself is not enough necessarily
but it's it's important and it's
important partly because in the final
draft of the report they left all that
out and the Central Committee decided to
not say anything about it in any public
statement concerning Stalin's death the
most important thing to my mind though
is a what must have been a conscious
falsification and the doctors knew it to
be so they had to have known it to be so
the doctors were called on the scene at
seven o'clock in the morning on March
the second in their report they say on
on the night of March the second meaning
the early mornings of March the second
the early hours of March the second
Comrade Stalin or Josef Vissarionovich
Stalin experienced a sudden loss of
consciousness now that makes it sound as
follows Stalin is unconscious and the
doctors are called
maybe Stalin becomes unconscious at two
o'clock in the morning he's discovered
at five o'clock by seven o'clock the
doctors are there then that seems almost
normal
the problem with this is that Stalin did
not become unconscious on that night it
was the night before it was the night
before and the doctors had no way of
knowing that you see
and therefore for them to have said on
the night of March the second means that
they put something into their report or
somebody else put something into their
report knowing it to be false so we have
a falsified medical report that has been
essentially covered up all these fifty
years we have a description of symptoms
that are at variance with a stroke
scenario and we have something else
which is the description of the
treatment they gave Stalin itself which
when I showed it to several doctors they
couldn't believe their eyes I mean they
gave him leeches now why would they get
why would you give somebody a leech
leeches were given to relieve blood
pressure and I didn't know this but a
doctor informed me of this the leech
introduces an anticoagulant into the
blood and therefore you see if you're
suffering from a clot well it will
release it it'll it'll break the clot
down but if you're suffering from a
hemorrhage it will accelerate the
effects of the hemorrhage and the
doctors had no way of knowing at that
time which it was and so this raises
serious questions now the theory that
was put forward by one of the doctors at
Yale I showed this - who didn't know
anything about Stalin's death and he
said to me look it's conceivable you
know it's possible that he died of a
hemorrhage and they gave him the
treatment they thought they should give
him but he said if there's any other
reason to suspect that he might have
been murdered I would think that the
poison of choice was warfarin warfarin
but he said I'm not sure that warfarin
was invented in 1953 so I did research
on this and what I discovered was that
warfarin was patented in 1950 in Madison
Wisconsin and it was aggressively
marketed worldwide and the and Berea who
had a whole workshop of poisons in the
KGB could certainly have had access to
this now the beauty of warfarin is as
follows
you know Stalin was very paranoid and if
you had dinner with him you would have
to taste his food a little bit of his
wine a little bit of his kasha a little
whatever was and so if it was strychnine
or arsenic or any one of these poisons
you would die but if it were warfarin
you wouldn't why because warfarin is an
anticoagulant and in small doses it's
very good for your heart in fact it was
given to Eisenhower when he suffered his
heart attack in 1954 but in slightly
elevated doses over a period of five
days it will kill you but if all of us
in this room were given five pounds of
warfarin to eat right now
we would walk home and be okay none of
us would die as a consequence of it so
it was a perfect poison because
everybody who had dinner with Stalin on
that last night of February
twenty-seventh could have had a little
sip of his wine could have tasted his
kasha could have had a bit of the cutlet
and have been perfectly fine the next
day only Stalin who I hypothesize with
no muff had been given it in doses over
a period of five or six days would have
died and going into why we hypothesized
that this was something that could have
happened over a period of five or six
days is a whole other McGillis
yes okay one more one more
pelipper Oh members that died are the
Central Committee members that died by
the doctors hands so-called did they die
with a bullet in their head or did they
die of medical issues they they all had
heart attacks everybody heads hog attack
everybody had a hard enough public
interest in having an autopsy done
because one of the doctors told me that
he thought that the warfarin could be
the traces of it not of the chemical
itself as might be the case with a
different kind of poison but the effects
of it on the vascular system could be
found mineka get a tissue sample yeah of
course he was involved they were all
involved and and they would take the
organs out and put them in glass jars
and keep them on exhibit in the Kremlin
Hospital some people that you he'd
normal it employed to taste his food
also died you would see some of the
members of his immediate well it's
possible if the same person tasted his
food every day but if they had a little
variation than they wouldn't
thank you